Las mascarillas se han convertido en el símbolo
de la pandemia. En el futuro, les contaremos
a nuestros nietos cómo teníamos que llevar
la mascarilla a todas partes durante los años
que duró la pandemia del Coronavirus. Sin
embargo…¿Y si te dijera que… durante
los primeros meses de la pandemia, la OMS
desaconsejaba el uso de mascarilla? Tal vez
lo hayáis olvidado. Pero hubo un tiempo donde
muchos epidemiólogos y hasta divulgadores
científicos dedicaron vídeos enteros explicando
por qué NO teníamos que usar mascarilla.
En aquel momento, tanto YouTube como el resto
de plataformas publicaron unas reglas para
evitar las fake news del Coronavirus. Una
de esas reglas era no contradecir los consejos
de la OMS. A fin de cuentas, la OMS es la
mayor autoridad sanitaria en el mundo. Si
hay alguien que pueda decir lo que es verdad
o es mentira en el mundo de la medicina, esa
es la Organización Mundial de la Salud. Sin
embargo, ahora sabemos que las mascarillas
son útiles para evitar los contagios de coronavirus.
Dicho de otra forma… si hasta la OMS se
equivoca a la hora de determinar que es y
que no es una fake news… ¿Cómo podemos
evitar los bulos en internet? ¿Cómo podemos
identificarlos? ¿De verdad se pueden censurar
estos bulos sin cercenar la libertad de expresión?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
Hay dos ideas que siempre se nos olvidan cuando
hablamos del debate de la censura y las fake
news. El primero es que no sólo hablamos
de libertad de expresión: también hablamos
del trabajo de mucha gente. Pensadlo así:
VisualPolitik no es sólo un medio de comunicación.
También es una empresa que nos da de comer
a los que la hemos creado. Si de repente un
día YouTube decidiera quitarnos el canal,
nos veríamos en la calle de un día para
otro. Sería como, si de repente, todos los
centros comerciales del mundo decidieran echar
a todos los ZARAS: hablaríamos de miles de
personas en la calle.
¡Pero no sólo eso! Otro de los grandes errores
al hablar de este tema es hablar de las BIG
TECH por igual. El mismo Trump ha denunciado
por igual a Twitter, Facebook y Google…
Y lo cierto es que hablamos de tres empresas
completamente distintas.
Aquí tenéis a la CEO de YouTube, Susan Wokcicki,
aquí al CEO de Facebook, Mark Zuckerberg
y, el último pero no por ello menos importante…
¡El CEO de Twitter, Jack Dorsey! De verdad,
quedaos con la cara de Jack Dorsey porque
va a ser muy importante en esta historia ¿Cómo
os lo digo…? ¿Habéis oído alguna vez
eso de que “las apariencias engañan”?
Pues, creedme, Jack Dorsey es un ejemplo de
que, a veces, las apariencias no engañan
para nada. Pero de eso hablaremos más adelante.
Ahora vamos a centrarnos en el fenómeno de
las fake news. Atentos.
CUANDO YA NO SABEMOS LO QUE ES VERDAD
Puede que os sorprenda, pero las fake news
no son ningún invento de nuestra época.
Os puedo dar un ejemplo de nada menos que
1898. Ese fue el año en el que estalló la
Guerra entre España y Cuba. Guerra donde
Estados Unidos apoyó al bando cubano. Pues
bien, todo esto empezó por una noticia falsa
publicada en un periódico: “The Morning
Journal”. Seguro Probablemente este nombre
no os diga gran cosa… pero muchos conozcáis
a su fundador: Willian Randolph Hearst. Y
seguro que muchos habréis oído alguna vez
su famosa frase. Esta es, literalmente, la
frase que dijo Hearst al periodista que escribió
la noticia.
“Usted ponga las fotos y yo pongo la guerra”
--William Randolph Hearst, founder The Morning
Journal
La diferencia es que ahora tenemos Internet.
Eso significa que cada vez más gente podemos
tener un medio de comunicación y llegar a
audiencias globales. Y eso significa una palabra:
competencia. Hace sólo 20 años, cada país
tenía unos pocos periódicos de tirada nacional.
Estos periódicos se repartían la audiencia
y la tarta publicitaria. Los ingresos permitían
pagar grandes plantillas y grandes rotativas.
Si habéis visto la redacción de cualquier
periódico tradicional, habréis visto que
son auténticas fábricas. Una rotativa es
una fábrica de hacer periódicos… y os
aseguro que nos barata. La redacción de un
periódico como New York Times puede tener
cientos de trabajadores. Sin embargo, ahora
esos medios compiten con periódicos online.
Los precios de la publicidad son cada vez
más bajos. Y los grandes medios siguen teniendo
muchas facturas que pagar. A esto hay que
sumarle otro factor: sólo el 30% de los lectores
de periódicos entra directamente en las páginas
web. El resto hacen click a través de noticias
que encuentran en redes sociales. Todo esto
explica una carrera salvaje por conseguir
más clicks que nadie. Y eso explica que tan
a menudo nos encontremos con titulares como
este.
El porno en streaming produce tanto CO2 como
Bélgica
News Scientist 11-07-2019
Pensadlo bien: un vídeo de VisualPolitik
como este que estáis viendo ahora requiere
días enteros de investigación. Eso son horas
de trabajo. Una noticia falsa, o poco rigurosa,
es mucho más barata de escribir: se puede
hacer en minutos y puede generar tanto o más
tráfico. Basta con que confirme nuestros
sesgos ideológicos para que la demos por
buena, la leamos y la compartamos. Pero ya
sé lo que estás pensando: todo esto es un
problema… pero no son fake news como tal.
Sin embargo, todos sabemos que hay auténticas
fake news. Es decir, noticias que no es que
sean sensacionalistas sino que son directamente
falsas. Incluso muchas de ellas se publican
en páginas web que imitan a la perfección
la línea gráfica de periódicos muy conocidos.
Os doy un ejemplo.
Singapur respalda una criptodivisa oficial
y la establece como su moneda oficial
¿BBC Noticias? 13-03-2019
Por si alguien lo estaba pensando: no, esta
noticia NO es de la BBC. Es de una web random
que imita a la BBC. Y es una mentira lo suficiente
creíble como para que mucha gente se la crea.
Y la pregunta, la auténtica pregunta es ¿Quién
puede estar interesado en imitar ser un periódico
legítimo para difundir bulos? La respuesta
está en la política. Y eso nos lleva a hablar
de países como…
¡Exacto! La madre Rusia. Existen infinitas
evidencias de que el Gobierno Ruso ha creado
campañas de fake news y de bots para manipular
la política de otros países. Y no, en este
caso no estamos hablando de las elecciones
de Estados Unidos en 2016. Por supuesto que,
en ese caso, Rusia intentó manipular la campaña.
Pero, por muchos esfuerzos que pusiera el
Kremlin, es difícil competir con los medios
de Estados Unidos. Sin embargo… ¿Sabéis
cuales son los países que más han sufrido
los efectos de las Fake News? Pues no, no
son ni Estados Unidos ni ningún gran país.
Hablamos de los países Bálticos. Pensadlo
bien: son países muy pequeños, con medios
muy pequeños y con poco presupuesto. Basta
con que el Kremlin haga una pequeña inversión
para crear medios de propaganda que compitan
con los medios locales. De hecho, en la capital
de Letonia, en Riga, hay un centro especial
de la OTAN para combatir la desinformación.
Y aquí es donde empezamos a hablar de temas
serios. Las fake news se han convertido en
un problema político. Un problema que muchos
quieren solucionar con leyes ¿Cómo? Ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver.
¿POLÍTICOS LUCHANDO CONTRA LA MENTIRA?
Si pensabais que este título es un oxímoron,
esperad porque aún no habéis visto nada
¿Cuál ha sido uno de los primeros países
en legislar contra las fake news? Venta, pensad
la respuesta: 3, 2, 1…
Rusia aprueba una ley para prohibir las fake
news y los insultos online a oficiales del
Gobierno
Financial Times 07-03-2019
¿A qué esta no os la veíais venir? Y no
penséis que esta ley es papel mojado. En
mayo de 2021, Rusia amenazó con prohibir
twitter si no cumplía con su ley. Al final,
la historia terminó con que Rusia pidió
a las empresas de telecomunicaciones que redujeran
la velocidad con la que se cargaba Twitter
en el país.
Y diréis ¡Vale! Esto es lo que ocurre en
Rusia. Pero ¿Qué está pasando en el mundo
democrático? Pues atentos porque ahora vamos
a viajar a…
¡Alemania! La semana pasada ya os contamos
cómo las autoridades Alemanas tienen una
larga historia denunciando a periodistas.
No sólo es porque quieran evitar discursos
neonazis. También hay denuncias por supuestas
fake news. Atentos.
La autoridad reguladora financiera alemana
presenta una denuncia criminal contra el Financial
Times
The Telegraph 17-04-2019
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué Alemania denunció
al Financial Times? Pues muy simple: por haber
destapado el escándalo de Wirecard. Si queréis
conocer la historia completa, os la contamos
aquí, en VisualPolitik, hace casi un año.
Tenéis el vídeo en la descripción.
Ya sabéis que aquí, en VisualPolitik, no
somos muy dados a las teorías de la conspiración.
Pero tenemos que reconocer que muchos escándalos
como el Watergate o el escándalo Wirecard
empezaron siendo teorías de la conspiración.
Y aquí es donde llega el gran debate ¿Las
fake news son un problema? Absolutamente.
Pero ¿Cómo sabemos distinguir lo que es
fake news de lo que no? ¿Quién puede dictar
lo que es la verdad? ¿De verdad podemos confiar
ciegamente en lo que dice la Organización
Mundial de la Salud? ¿Podemos fiarnos ciegamente
de lo que dicen los reguladores financieros
alemanes? ¿Podemos fiarnos de los muchos
epidemiólogos de distintos países que aseguraban
que el Coronavirus no sería un problema?
¡Por supuesto! Todo el mundo tiene derecho
a cometer errores. Pero, precisamente por
eso, es tan peligroso darle a unas pocas instituciones
el poder de censurar lo que creen que es mentira.
Y precisamente por eso, por lo difícil que
es hacer leyes en contra de las fake news,
la Unión Europea está mirando en esta dirección.
La Comisión Europea cree que la auto-regulación
es el mejor camino para lidiar con las fake
news
Garrigues News 06-25-2018
Si habéis visto el anterior vídeo de esta
serie, ya conocéis los peligros que tiene
la autocensura. En algunos casos, puede ser
incluso peor que la censura impuesta por un
gobierno. Pero la pregunta, la auténtica
pregunta es ¿Cómo puede funcionar un modelo
así? Si recordáis, las 3 mayores plataformas
de contenido online son Facebook (donde está
también Instagram), Twitter y YouTube (que
son parte del grupo Alphabet). La pregunta
es ¿De verdad son empresas tan distintas?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
¿QUIÉN CENSURA EN INTERNET?
Os voy a contar una anécdota personal. Como
sabéis, VisualPolitik tiene un perfil de
Twitter con 60.000 seguidores. Llevamos más
de 5 años con este perfil. Sin embargo, todavía
no hemos conseguido que Twitter nos verifique
la cuenta. Es decir, que técnicamente podría
llegar cualquiera y crearse un perfil con
nuestro nombre y nuestro perfil y hablar en
nuestro nombre. Y diréis ¿Por qué no estamos
verificados en Twitter? Pues lo cierto es
que nadie lo sabe. Hemos preguntado por todas
partes cómo se verifica un perfil y la respuesta
siempre es la misma: “tienes que conocer
a alguien de la empresa que te haga el favor”
¡Sí! ¡Habéis oído bien! Twitter: una
de las redes sociales más grandes del mundo,
funciona como si fuera el restaurante de tu
barrio. Y todo esto tiene una explicación.
Fijaos en este dato: en el momento en el que
hacemos este vídeo, las acciones de Twitter
valen 66 dólares. Las de Facebook están
en 361 dólares y las de Alphabet (es decir,
las del grupo donde está Google y YouTube)
valen, atentos… 2700 dólares. Para que
os hagáis una idea, Twitter tiene 5500 empleados
en todo el mundo, Facebook tiene 60000 y Alphabet
tiene más de 132.000 empleados. Y diréis
¿Pero todo esto qué tiene que ver con las
fake news? ¡Pues mucho! Porque hacer un filtro
que modere las fake news es MUY caro y requiere
un ejército de programadores. YouTube puede
permitírselo. Otras empresas tienen que recurrir
a otras prácticas bastante más cuestionables.
Y aquí es donde volvemos a la foto del principio.
Fijaos en los distintos CEOS: la de YouTube,
el de Facebook y… el de Twitter.
Os presento a JACK DORSEY, considerado por
varios medios financieros como uno de los
peores CEOs de Estados Unidos. Para que os
hagáis una idea, incluso los propios accionistas
de Twitter han llegado a planificar revueltas
internas para echarlo. Y diréis ¿Pero por
qué es tan terrible este hombre? Pues bien,
desde el principio, Jack Dorsey no quiso que
su empresa diera beneficios. La idea original
era que Twitter fuera una especie de fundación
al estilo Wikipedia. Una especie de servicio
público. De hecho, Twitter tiene una larga
tradición colaborando con el Gobierno de
Estados Unidos. Y lo cierto es que Jack Dorsey
ha llegado a decir públicamente que lo suyo
es la política. Atentos.
Jack Dorsey, CEO de Twitter, quiere ser alcalde
de Nueva York
CNN 18-03-2013
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos!
¿Dónde está el problema? ¿Desde cuando
es malo no querer que tu empresa de beneficios?
Pues el problema es muy simple: si no quieres
mancharte las manos con sucio dinero, no puedes
mantener una plantilla grande trabajadores.
Y si no tienes programadores y, a la vez,
quieres poder sacar pecho con una red social
100% libre de “contenido dañino”, terminas
con cosas como esta.
Twitter suspende la cuenta de la actriz Rose
McGowan después de que hable en contra del
abuso sexual
Gizmodo 10-12-2017
Existen miles de casos de cuentas suspendidas
en Twitter sin razón aparente. Cuentas que
se vuelven a activar a los pocos días. En
el año 2016, Twitter borró cuentas que hacían
sátira de políticos rusos. Días después
volvieron a aparecer ¿Por qué? Nadie lo
sabe. Los criterios de Twitter para borrar
cuentas son totalmente arbitrarios. Por comparar,
YouTube tiene un algoritmo que sigue unas
reglas muy claras. Esas reglas están publicadas
en la propia página de YouTube. Si tenéis
un canal de YouTube y nunca habéis leído
estas reglas, las encontraréis en los enlaces
de la descripción.
Además, la propia empresa ofrece cursos para
los creadores donde se puede ver muy claro
lo que se puede y lo que no se puede hacer.
Por si todo esto fuera poco, existe un sistema
de apelaciones. Es decir, que si mañana YouTube
quitara este vídeo, podría enviar una solicitud.
Y puedo deciros por experiencia propia que
el sistema de apelaciones funciona. Al menos
conozco dos canales que fueron recuperados
tras un proceso de apelaciones. Por cierto,
que si estás viendo este vídeo y tienes
un canal que acaban de banear, también puedes
encontrar el link para recuperarlo en la descripción.
Y, por cierto, hablando de YouTube, este es
un momento perfecto para recordaros que aquí,
en VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribíos a este canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones. Pero volvamos
con nuestra historia… ¿Tiene YouTube el
mejor sistema del mundo? Posiblemente no.
Pero al menos es un sistema. En el caso de
Twitter, hay muy poco de eso. De hecho, hay
muchos canales en YouTube que están permitidos
pero que tienen su cuenta baneada en Twitter.
Ese es el caso, por ejemplo, de Un Tío Blanco
Hetero, que es un canal español que habla
de opinión política. Como todos los canales
de opinión, es controvertido. Es uno de los
canales más grandes de este tema en YouTube
España. Sin embargo, en Twitter ha sido retirado
varias veces.
De hecho, las políticas para bloquear cuentas
de Twitter son tan arbitrarias que varían
de un país a otro. En Estados Unidos o en
Europa, el enemigo es el discurso del odio
y las fake news. En Turquía, el enemigo son
todos los políticos que se opongan a Erdogan
¿No me creéis? Pues echad un vistazo a esta
noticia.
En una revision de más de 700 cuentas retenidas
en Turquía , más de 600 pertenecían a los
militantes de movimientos pro kurdos y afiliados
al predicador islámico Fetulah Gulen, que
está en el exilio. El gobierno turco culpa
a Gulen y a sus seguidores de tener un rol
en el golpe de estado de 2016.
Buzzfeednews 24-01-2018
Y si el sistema ya funciona mal, las propuestas
de mejora son aún peor. Atentos.
Os presentamos Birdwatch, una estrategia basada
en la comunidad para combatir la desinformación
Twitter Blog 25-01-2021
Esta estrategia para combatir la desinformación
consiste en un grupo de twitteros seleccionados
por el propio Twitter que se dedicarán a
denunciar tweets que desinformen. La empresa
ya está haciendo pruebas en Estados Unidos
con 100 verificadores que, ya han dicho que
“vienen de distintas ideologías”. Dicho
de otra forma, a falta de dinero para herramientas,
Twitter recurre a gente física que verifique
las noticias. Y aquí es donde volvemos a
la idea del principio: no sólo estamos hablando
de libertad de expresión. También hablamos
del trabajo de mucha gente. Detrás de muchas
cuentas grandes de Twitter, YouTube o Facebook
está el modo de vida de mucha gente. Dejar
todo eso en manos del capricho de un grupo
de personas presionadas por políticos, sesgos
ideológicos y ¿Por qué no? Enemistades
personales… no es una buena idea.
Dicho de otra forma, que tal vez no deberíamos
plantearnos si las plataformas deben autorregularse
sino… si las plataformas deben garantizar
los derechos de los creadores. Y, en este
sentido, no todas las plataformas actúan
igual. Así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros ¿Creéis que las plataformas deberían
hacer un mayor esfuerzo para evitar las fake
news? ¿O tal vez deberían hacer justo lo
contrario y permitir cualquier tipo de contenido?
Y lo que es más importante ¿Creéis que
Twitter debería responder ante sus usuarios
por tener unas prácticas tan arbitrarias?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Por cierto, que si queréis profundizar en
este tema de las fake news, os dejo una conferencia
que dio nuestro querido compañero de canal,
Enrique Couto. Como siempre, no olvidéis
que aquí, en VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un saludo y hasta
pronto.